don't look for any reconciliation
between chris rock and will smith
anytime soon chris sounding off on the
oscar slap at a comedy show and on that
offer to host next year's oscars well
for chris that was between a rock and a
hard no
[Applause]
chris told the audience he turned down
the oscar gig because hosting would be
like returning to the scene of the crime
joking it's like asking nicole brown
simpson to go back to the italian
restaurant where she left her glasses
when he started talking about it it was
just uproar of laughter
we spoke with january harrison who was
in the audience sunday night in phoenix
during the evening he did describe that
he declined an offer to go on to oprah
and do a sit-down interview and even a
super bowl commercial with will smith
himself he said you are not going to see
me on any interviews prying my heart out
about this i am not going to be a victim
chris also referenced will's 2001 role
as muhammad ali
words hurt and so does getting punched
in the jaw the guy's bigger than me he
came in playing ali and i couldn't even
play mayweather he definitely made a lot
of jokes about it but made it clear you
know he's not hurting he's not a victim
and he will he will survive
jokes aside chris has also kind of been
there done that with the oscars he's
hosted twice in 2016 he joked about jada
not being there jayla boycott in the
oscars is like me boycotting rihanna's
panties
i wasn't invited
as for will my behavior
was
unacceptable
we're told he is feeling much more
confident and less depressed hard to
believe how much has changed between
will and chris 15 months ago chris and
michelle joked about how they both
overstudied for acting roles
will smith said he used to do that too
because he was so scared because he
wasn't a good actor and he used to know
everybody's lines yeah i definitely had
such a fear of being called out for not
knowing my lines so yeah i
i get it will i get it
[Music]